[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
KRIS BRAUN: Hi.
Welcome to this
session on implementing
asynchronous
operations in your UI.
I'm Kris Braun, the
product lead for Workflows,
and I'll cover why
getting this right
leads to building
trustworthy applications.
Then my colleague
Guillaume Lafore
will share a couple variations
of a helpful pattern
for implementing asynchronous
operations in your UI using
Workflows along with Firestore.
Your app or website exists to do
the things users ask it to do.
That might be publishing
their brilliant article,
placing an order, or authorizing
access for a new employee.
User trust is the most valuable
thing your app can build--
or lose.
How often have you
experienced an app
that is flaky,
unreliable, or simply
doesn't give you the feedback
you need to know whether it's
working or not?
It only takes one or
two bad experiences
before I stop
trusting an app, which
leads me to avoid using it.
On the other hand, many apps
are so reliable that they
form unconscious habits
where I don't even
consider them failing to
do the thing that I ask.
Our goal as developers
is to create apps
that win that kind of trust.
The challenge is, many
things an app can do
may not be instantaneous.
Processing may take from several
seconds to several hours.
This might be because of the
complexity of the computation,
waiting for a limited
resource, or connection
to a real-world process
that just takes time,
like 3D printing.
In addition, many operations
involve multiple services
performing a chain of operations
to complete the overall task.
Reliably combining
these services
requires re-tries with
exponential backup,
which further
increases the runtime
in worst-case scenarios.
And then there's humans.
They're wonderful, really.
They can make pizzas and
authorize insurance claims.
But they're rarely
as fast as computers.
They often take days or
months to complete tasks.
I know Guillaume
had to wait longer
than he would have
liked for me to finish
my part of this session.
All of these factors contribute
to variable and long run times.
If any of them
apply, your UI needs
to take into account the
period of time the operation is
in progress rather than assuming
all operations are quick
and immediately successful.
Now, while an
operation is running,
a client UI might lose
its network connection,
crash, or simply be closed.
If the operation depends on
an HTTP request staying alive,
the real world will make
these operations unreliable.
You need your operation
to continue asynchronously
in the background,
running on your back end
regardless of what
happens to the front end.
So back to our user, who
asked our app to do something.
They need to see real-time
feedback to trust
that the app is working.
Few things create a more
uncomfortable user experience
than clicking a button and
having no idea if it worked,
or is working, or failed.
For multi-step processes,
seeing which step is current
can also be important.
Today we'll show how to
deliver this reliability
and reactivity.
Our pattern will use Workflows
to reliably perform the work
and Firestore to
drive a reactive UI.
Guillaume, over
to you to walk us
through this helpful pattern.
GUILLAUME LAFORE: Workflows
is a fully managed,
scalable service that
can orchestrate any APIs,
internal or external.
With Workflows, you can
externalize and monitor
the logic of your
business processes
and have it work
for you even when
your mobile application
or website aren't
running or active.
The workflow is made up steps,
and you can go through them,
loop through them, or
create different branches.
Steps can even run in parallel.
The two cool
aspects of Workflows
are that you can create
callback endpoints
that service can call back into
and that pauses your workflow.
And when the endpoint
is called, it
resumes the workflow execution.
And secondly, Workflows can
even run a super-long time,
even up to a year.
So you can support a very
rich set of possible business
workflows.
For storing the status of our
long-running and asynchronous
workflows, we decided to take
advantage of Google Cloud
Firestore.
Firestore is a great
NoSQL document database.
It's serverless,
it's fully managed,
so we don't have to worry about
the infrastructure management.
And it scales transparently.
It's also mobile-
and web-friendly.
And in particular, thanks
to the Firebase integration,
you can easily link
your UI to the data
stored in the database.
The icing on the cake is
the live synchronization
and offline mode capabilities.
In particular, in our use case
today, the live synchronization
enables our UIs to
be really reactive
and show changes as they
happen in the database.
Let's see that in
action with an example
showing a
pizza-ordering process,
combining Workflows to
orchestrate the steps
and Firestore to handle
real-time status updates.
In this demo, we are going
to submit some order--
for example, for a pizza.
We have several steps
in our workflow.
We received the
order; the payment
is going to be processed;
the order is being prepared;
then the order is shipped; and
at the end, it's delivered.
So you are going to receive,
for example, your pizza.
We're going to store
the state of our order
in the Firestore database.
So here I am seeing
the documents that
are stored in the database.
And at the bottom here, we
have the workflow execution.
So there were a few
executions in the past.
And we're going to see that
as soon as I submit the order,
a new execution is created.
And we'll have a look at the
status changes in the database.
As soon as we go through one
of the steps of the workflow,
we're going to update the
state in the database.
And if you look at the UI, the
website, mobile application,
et cetera will be
notified in real time
that we went through a
new step in our workflow
and we will update
the UI accordingly.
So let's submit the order.
I click on the Submit button.
It is going to create
a new workflow here.
So it's currently executing.
And you can see
that at each step,
the status is
changing-- prepared;
now it's going to be shipped.
As soon as rewriting
the database,
we update the UI, turning
from gray into black
and showing some ingredients.
And at the end you see that
the workflow succeeded.
We went through all the steps
of our workflow execution,
with status changes
updating the UI live.
To recap, when the user clicks
the button, the Submit button,
the client-side JavaScript
calls the Google Cloud function
that triggers the
execution of the workflow.
For each key step
of the process,
Workflows calls and
orchestrates various services
to process the payment,
to prepare the order,
ship the order, et cetera.
And after each of these steps,
if they execute successfully,
you update a status field
in Firestore for that order.
Thanks to the Firebase SDK
running in the web page
or mobile front
end, the front end
is notified that a change has
been made to the database.
Then the UI is
updated pretty much
in real time with
the status change.
On the client-side
JavaScript code,
there are two key things
that we need to do.
The first thing is to subscribe
to real-time notifications
of the changes to
the document related
to that particular
order in Firestore.
When there's a change
in the status data,
the onSnapshot event
handler is called,
and we can update the
UI via some DOM changes.
The other important
thing to do is
to call the Cloud function,
thanks to the fetch method,
to trigger the execution of
the order-processing workflow.
The client-side JavaScript code
invokes this Cloud function,
whose job is to trigger the
execution of the workflow.
For that purpose, we use
Workflows Execution npm Module
and its createExecution method.
We pass the order ID as a
parameter to the workflow.
But we should also send
the details of our order,
with the ingredients of
the pizza, et cetera.
Let's have a quick look at the
workflow definition showing
the two operations we
combined for each step.
First of all, in
this extract, a step
calls the service that
prepares the order.
And the following step updates
the status in Firestore.
Interestingly, updating
a field in the document
in the Firestore database is
really just a declarative goal
in the workflow definition.
No need to write actual
database handling code.
We rely on Firestore's APIs
that Workflows can call
in that declarative manner.
Here we're actually
using a special connector
for Firestore.
We're not calling its REST
API manually directly.
It simplifies the
usage of the API.
We mentioned that
humans can be part
of those long-running
processes and may
need to validate, authorize,
give their go, no-go agreement.
So how do we handle
those situations?
That's where we'll benefit from
another Workflows features,
HTTP callbacks.
I'd like to show you another
demo, with a smart expense
report application
where a manager needs
to approve the expense
report sent by their team.
In such an application, we
need someone to take a decision
and approve or
reject the reports.
Let's have a look at an
expense report application.
We have two views.
The first is the employee view.
The employee is going
to submit receipts,
and it's going to create
an expense report.
The manager here on the right--
we'll go into the
administration page--
and the manager will wait
for incoming expense reports.
The incoming reports will
be here in the queue,
in the waiting-approval queue.
On the left, the
employee is going
to select a few
receipts-- so let's
say, this one and
perhaps this one.
The two receipts are selected.
Now let's submit the report.
So we're going to go
through different steps
of our workflow.
Submit the report.
Receipts are added.
Receipts are sent.
The report is now
being processed.
So we saw a couple or three
steps very fast in the UI,
because the UI is updated
pretty much in real time
as soon as there's a
status update after one
of the steps of the workflow.
So now the report
is being processed.
We are using Document
AI to parse receipts.
It's going to look at the
information in those receipts--
all the line items, the amount
of each item, the total,
the currency, also the
location where it's been--
if it's a restaurant, et cetera.
We'll have some
interesting information
that the manager will
have to have a look at
and say, OK, this is a
legit expense report.
I will approve or reject
this expense report.
So let's wait a
little bit while it's
being processed by Document AI.
Look, it appeared.
So we now have the
expense report.
Notice also there were
actually two real-time updates
or changes in those two UIs.
There's the report that appears
in the manager's
queue, and we also
have the new state, the new
status here, saying report
is awaiting validation.
So now the workflow is
posed and is waiting
for the manager's feedback.
And for that purpose
we're going to use
a great feature of Workflows,
Workflows Callbacks.
So the UI for the manager is
going to call back the workflow
to say, OK, here's my decision.
I approve or I reject
this expense report.
Document AI gave
useful information--
the two restaurants, the
items, the total, the currency,
et cetera.
So we've got all the
right information.
And, well, it seems
that my employee
was traveling, so he had some
expenses at a restaurant.
So that's great.
I'm going to approve
the expense report.
I approve it, and look-- it
disappears from my queue.
And as an employee, I
see report validated.
The manager has
validated my report.
So I had status updates at
each step of the workflow.
And the workflow
was posed, waiting
for the validation or
rejection by the manager,
using Workflows callback.
Here's a recap of what's
happening under the hood.
The employee uses the
website to store the receipts
into Cloud Storage, thanks
to the Firebase SDK.
The app triggers the
workflow execution
via the Cloud function.
The workflow calls the
Document AI service
to figure out the
various line items
of the receipts, the total
amount, the currency,
the vendor, et cetera.
All those receipt
details are stored
in the Firestore database.
Then in the management
view, the manager
will see a new expense report
arrive, ready for their review.
That's where the callback
system comes into play.
The workflow is posed,
waiting for the decision
of the manager.
The manager sees all the
details about the expense
report and its receipts, and
can then click Accept or Reject.
When either of these
buttons is clicked,
then the admin UI is
going to call the callback
endpoint via another
Cloud function,
and that will resume the
execution of the workflow.
The acceptance or
rejection decision
is stored in Firestore.
And again, thanks to the
live synchronization feature,
the UI will be updated live for
the employee at the same time,
and they will see in the
report if the report was
accepted or rejected.
We, again, combined workflows
for reliably executing
a process, even waiting
for a human intervention,
updating the database, and
notifying all the stakeholders
live as changes are made.
Let me highlight the two key
steps in the workflow that take
care of the callback mechanism.
The first step here creates
a callback endpoint.
So that means there
is a special URL that
has been created that is going
to be open and be reachable
so that some external service
can call back when it's ready,
when it's done.
Then the second step
is where we pause
the execution of the
workflow to wait for the call
to the callback endpoint.
How do we take
advantage of this?
Well, from the UI,
when the manager
clicks on the Approve
or Reject button,
this callback endpoint
is going to be
called, via Cloud function, with
the outcome of the decision.
And then the workflow
can resume its execution.
Of course, depending on the
approval or rejection status,
you can have different branches
of execution in your workflow
and do further
steps conditionally.
Although it's not
shown in these two
extracts of the whole
workflow, at each key step
of the process, we
are saving the status
of the process in Firestore,
like in the previous demo,
so that the UI
updates in real time
as we progress
through the workflow
and the various statuses.
From the front end, we
call the Cloud function
that will be responsible for
calling the callback endpoint.
So here in this admin.js
JavaScript file,
we are calling that
Cloud function,
passing the callback
URL we want to reach,
and also the approval status--
if that expense report has
been accepted or rejected.
In the Cloud function,
on the server side,
we relay the call to the
Workflows callback endpoint.
We need to authenticate to
call the callback endpoint;
hence why we're
using the GoogleAuth
library to get an access token.
Then we call the actual URL
of the callback endpoint,
passing the access token as
the bearer token and the status
as payload.
Now back at you, Kris,
for the last step
of the workflow of our talk.
KRIS BRAUN: What
Guillaume has shown
us here is a very useful
pattern for trusted apps that
can be applied widely.
Workflows ensures resilience to
failures in your front-end app
and back-end services.
Operations that take time
for processing, retries,
and actions are
easily incorporated.
You can rest easy knowing
Workflows is keeping things
running as expected.
If any back-end services
fail, your workflow
can specify exactly
what should happen,
and you can observe the details
to remediate any failures.
Firestore handles all the
magic required for your UI
to display the real-time
status of the operation
as it progresses.
Operation status is current
even if the page is reloaded
or the app is restarted.
Together, Workflows
and Firestore
deliver the reliability
and reactivity
your app needs to
win users' trust.
We look forward to seeing
what you'll empower your users
to do through this pattern.
Thank you for watching.
Guillaume and I are
always happy to talk
about serverless
application architecture,
so please reach out with
any questions or ideas.
Happy building.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]